britney spears is one step closer to
freedom her father jamie spears has been
suspended as her conservator the
suspension will remain in place until a
future court date and e.t was on the
scene when news broke of the
game-changing ruling a huge victory for
britney spears this afternoon her fans
went wild cheering and yelling as news
broke that her father jamie spears has
been suspended from her conservatorship
brittany's fiance sam escari shared his
reaction on his instagram story writing
simply free britney congratulations and
as the pop star herself might put it
this is just a groundbreaking day it's
unclear how soon to expect brittany's
next court date but we do know this the
singer's attorney matthew rosengart
requested a termination hearing in the
next 30 to 45 days for the time being
cpa john zabel has been named britney's
temporary conservator e.t also learned
that the new york times documentary
controlling britney spears was a major
topic throughout the hearing her own
phone and her own private conversations
were used so often to control her
wednesday's development follows the
release of three separate documentaries
all focused on britney's conservatorship
a source tells e.t quote britney is
definitely affected by all of these new
documentaries coming out about her life
this is the fight for her life and she
feels really close to winning it any and
all methods that will help her move this
process along she welcomes it i don't
think any conservatorship attorney in
this country has seen a case like
britney's e.t also spoke with tamar
armanek who was the conservatorship
attorney for amanda bynes so much is
involved so much press so much media
just the general fame and power that the
conservative came with into the
conservatorship and the fact that she's
continued to work and earn an amazing
living while on this conservatorship is
very unusual
[Applause]
also outside the courthouse a crowd of
passionate britney supporters proudly
displaying emblems of the free britney
movement i just want to be a happy
person in britney's bombshell testimony
from june the singer said her father
should be punished for the handling of
her conservatorship rosengart has said
he plans to continue investigating
jamie's conduct throughout the
conservatorship brittany has said
she wants some of her family members in
jail what actual charges could jaime
potentially face all of jamie's actions
financial and otherwise have had
the approval of the court so i'm not
sure how far conservatorship abuse
charges are going to go but it seems to
me
very clear to be very clear that mr
rosengard has said he's going to look at
what jaime did over the last 13 years
under a microscope now it's up to
britney what the future holds for her
career and personal life am i going to
take the stage again will i ever take
the stage again
i have no idea we do know brittany has a
wedding to plan
look at that
you like it she and sam her fiance
announced their engagement earlier this
month
[Music]